This is tracking.
This is a tough fact. That's the job.
They want him arrested.
They just handed Donald Trump
the Republican nomination.
He's sort of get reelected.
I'm telling you, we made the call
every once in a while.
I do cringe on
some of the things he says.
But on the Donald Trump,
we had a great economy
and we weren't at war.
I'm a one to Santa supporter,
but now I support Donald Trump.
It's just about accountability.
We want Trump to have a fair trial.
You know,
we just want him to be treated
like any other American.
TRUMP
What do you think
that will have an impact
on the 2024 election?
Yeah, I think in a positive way
that I think Trump's going to nail that.
Like, I love DeSantis,
but I don't think he even has a chance
against Trump
because people are really
fired up about this.
Like, why has this happened?
Yeah.
Like, they don't see the merit
and everything that's going on.
I think that
it's a fair argument to say that
this is probably going to amp up
Trump's base
a bit and I'm not necessarily
worried about that because I kind of see
2024 as Trump in two
Santas eating each other alive.
So I think the fear that
this might propel
Trump into
the presidency is a bit overblown.
If that was a politically motivated
thing and for an ex-president, it's
one Mr.
ex-President, in my opinion,
should be treated with respect to
whatever party they belong to,
whether you like him or hate him.
This country was better off economy.
We were saved.
The first president in 40 years
and we never had a war.
And I could go on and on.
Is he perfect?
No. Is he God? No.
But I'll tell you one thing.
He backed the blue.
We were safe
and everything was so much better.
It's a nice feeling to see some justice
finally starting to happen,
but at the same time
it kind of feels like
it's the beginning of the or
the tip of the iceberg.
I think this is going to be
an incredible moment in American history.
I just think that it's
I think that people are going to start
to realize what is actually happened
over the past eight years.
And and
there were
and I think the entire country
is going to step back into itself.